The URI or
uniform resource identifier is the path
to find resources provided by your API.
This means that our URI should
always refer to resources and
not to actions being
performed on those resources.
And it is recommended to use
the plural form for each resource name.
HTTP provides us with eight verbs,
or methods,
we can use to indicate
the desired method of action.
We want a server to take
on an API endpoint.
There's no rule forcing you
to use all of these verbs.
But it's a good practice
to use them responsibly.
Head and get requests can be
called by search engines and
web crawlers exploring the Internet.
Make sure these requests only
provide information, but
never modify your database,
or the state of your backend.
HTTP also has status codes to indicate
the different types of responses
a server can send back to the client.
A good API should take advantage of
these status codes for successful and
erroneous HTTP responses.
Error messages you send to your
users should be concise, clear, and
informative.
Proper URI paths, HTTP verbs, and error
messages are all important components
for making your APIs understandable,
and easily implementable.